there's a guy fighter and a kid is
really fun to listen to yeah so listen
to fighter and kid podcast yeah it's a
great pod I implore you ders also I'm
messing to say name a brown he did it
zombie cage fighter series he's from
Washington State why am i messing his
name up man I'm sorry I can't you have
to computer open right now look up
zombie cage fighter that's Nate Nathan
quarry rock quarry
Nathan named rock quarry
Nathan rock quarries Oh okay so here's
that's part of my traumatic brain injury
I ask memory issues sometimes but I
swear man look up Nathan rock quarry
rock quarry he he is the coolest guy and
his guys UFC fighting champion he's
awesome he's tough but the guy has a
spiritual toughness that guy is an
intellectual toughness his compassionate
he's feeling the guy is amazing if I get
to grow up and I can be like one person
I would be like the rock man rock quarry
that guy is a coolest guy man look him
up okay i him on your show I I really
like this guy man and I swear he's also
on the same thing his legacy to have a
legacy of man of compassion of an
intellectual giant and he was a UFC
fight and tough guy you don't want to
mess with the guy well but is the
coolest guy man and that's what I want
with legacy to be just like Nathan rock
quarry you know that's how we need to
look at it if your light legacy is
one-dimensional and it's not very much
you know and that's why I talk about the
book of staff it's a book that I'm
writing it's not published yet but it's
a stabs man build your staffs up have a
lot of staffs and stabs are twofold
however you want to look at it if you
have a tall ladder you can climb up to
higher and higher levels of
consciousness higher and higher levels
of vibration more staff has more rungs
staff as a rung on the ladder however
you want to look at it you can look at
it but it's cool biggest abs mean two
things you know what I mean yeah it's so
so I just
climb high man do big stuff or to staff
your boats he can sail them many many
harsh waters you know so I love that
that's beautiful that that's that's
beautiful and I definitely look forward
to reading that book is that a cool way
to leave our show that is a very cool
way to leave our show Kristin thank you
so much for doing this I've learned so
very much from you I'm so grateful for
you doing this and for every one of me
you've done for the country if you want
to follow me follow me on Instagram it's
valor for us because Valor's not for me
and valor has no gender if ala has no
color valor has nothing valorous is
doesn't care Fowler's for us Valores for
all of us so valor for us on Instagram
Twitter Facebook all of them you can
find me
[Laughter]